hey guys today we're going to talk about
insulin we're gonna go beyond insulin a
lot of times people have this idea that
I need to lower my carb so I can lower
insulin and they think about
carbohydrates being the only thing that
affects insulin I'm gonna go beyond that
there's many different parts of this
puzzle so let's just kind of dive in so
let's start with sugar
okay glucose glucose will increase
insulin lactose this is milk sugar does
not increase insulin as much as glucose
and sucrose which is combination of
glucose and fructose has a different
effect on insulin so if we have a
hundred percent fructose that creates a
different response on insulin so you can
see the different sugars have different
responses out of all of these right here
this one right here is the most
dangerous so the difference between
fructose and other sugars is very very
different fructose is mainly handled by
your liver these other sugars can be
handled by different cells throughout
the body and organs but fructose is
mainly handled by the liver so when you
consume food high in fructose or
hydrogen's corn syrup or even worse
agave nectar you're going to overload
the liver
you are gonna spike insulin indirectly
but not directly the liver is going to
start to generate excessive fat as a
fatty liver and adipose tissue around
the organs so we're gonna have a huge
problem with this right here so if you
had a choice between fructose and other
sugars you want to go with the other
sugars and avoid fructose at all cost
okay now let's go to the next topic
which is basically consuming sugar in
combination with protein when you
combine these two together you increase
the insulin response by 200% so it's
exaggerated when you combine sugar with
fat you also increase the insulin
response by 200% so again it's
exaggerated so if you're gonna consume
these it's much better to consume them
separately not together so I'm just
talking about
the combination of certain foods you can
combine protein and fat and that's
totally fine but anytime you add sugar
that's when you actually create a lot of
problems with insulin and there's a lot
more data on this topic because when you
actually start combining this you start
creating a stickiness in your blood when
you create all sorts of protein deposits
in the brain and the heart and the
joints so that's a completely different
topic but all you need to know is that
the combination of these two will
exaggerate the spike of insulin let's go
to other carbohydrates in addition to
these sugars right here so you have
vegetable carbohydrates within the
vegetable family you have certain
vegetables that spike insulin more than
others simply because it has more
concentrated sugar and then you have
fruit which is even as more sugar less
fiber you have starches grains you have
the different processing of Grange of
very refined grains versus whole grains
they have different effects on insulin
vegetables create the least response and
insulin because it has the least amount
of sugar and has the most fiber now the
thing about fiber even though fiber is a
carbohydrate
it doesn't affect insulin so if we
combine fiber with something else it
actually helps buffer the insulin
response so let me give an example
not that you would consume orange juice
but let's say for example you eat an
orange versus during the juice from an
orange which is - is the fiber you're
gonna have a much greater spike of
insulin with the orange juice versus the
whole orange so fiber buffers insulin
response now fiber also feeds the
microbes in your gut and the microbes
then make a byproduct called butyrate
which helps blood sugars so fiber
actually helps lower insulin resistance
down the road from the gut from the
microbes okay so now let's talk about
alcohol there's different types of
alcohol and there's different insulin
response to alcohol so now let's switch
to a slightly different topic which is
the insulin index you may have heard of
the glycemic index which is kind of the
index of how fast
foods turn into sugar and raise your
blood sugar then you have something
called the insulin index which are foods
that raise insulin it doesn't really
have anything to do with the blood
sugars it has only to do with the
insulin what you want to do is consume
foods low on the insulin index so the
higher the number the greater the
response of insulin okay so with alcohol
beer is a 20 okay red wine is 15 so beer
is greater than red wine so beer has a
higher effect on insulin white wine is a
three so if you were to compare red wine
with white wine especially that's dry
not sweet you're going to create a much
less into the response if you consume
white wine then you have gin which has a
zero effect on the insulin index so you
might think oh I can dis consume gin
right unfortunately gin is very damaging
to your liver so it's gonna create all
sorts of other issues ok so just because
something might lower your insulin
doesn't make it a health food okay so I
recommend not even consuming any of
these maybe occasionally you want to
drink some alcohol but just realize that
where the alcohol is what creates the
damage to the liver in addition to the
responses of insulin okay
now let's get to the topic of fat fat
has the least response of insulin than
anything the more pure the fat the lower
on the insulin index it is now let's
just take for example you go to the
store and you buy tuna fish okay in a
can so you have tuna and water okay that
has insulin index response of twenty six
compared to tuna in the oil that has 16
so you can see just by adding the oil it
actually lowers the insulin response so
fat lowers the insulin in the body okay
and then we have let's say a potato chip
okay now this is basically a starch
which I'm not recommending I'm just
giving an example if we compare a potato
chip is 15 on the insulin index if we
compare that to a reduced-fat potato
chip it's 51 so the fattier of the chip
the least amount of insulin they're both
pretty high but the point is that one is
better than the other
let's take milk skim milk is sixty on
this scale 2% milk which has more fat is
20 so the fattier milk has three times
less incident response than the low-fat
milk interesting okay moving right along
I want to just mention sugar alcohols
this is not an alcohol this is an
alternative sweetener there's certain
sugar alcohols that create different
effect on the glycemic index okay
xylitol which is from birch bark
it's a sweetener tastes very similar to
sugar by the way has a low response on
the glycemic index 30 but it still has a
response
Reeth watal has a response of zero so I
just want to make the point that
different sugar alcohols have different
responses to either blood sugars or
insulin all right last topic we're going
to talk about is protein so when you
consume moderate amount of protein it
has a very small effect on insulin but
it does increase insulin a little bit
okay but if you take like meat or fish
it will not increase your blood Sugar's
but here's the thing when you increase
the volume of protein that's when you
start getting more of a spike of insulin
so a moderate amount of protein will
spike insulin maybe just slightly the
more protein you go the more insulin is
raised and here's the other interesting
point about this low-fat protein also
will increase insulin more than higher
fat protein so again the fat buffers the
insulin response
one of the greatest triggers to insulin
on the insulin scale is extremely low
fat lean protein which is whey protein
okay
so weight protein will greatly increase
insulin now it does other things too and
I'm not saying don't consume whey
protein but the point is that this can
create a spike in insulin and if you
already have a problem with blood sugars
the last thing you want to do is start
creating more insulin because the more
insulin that's spiked the more insulin
resistance you get okay for those of you
that are new here's insulin here's a
receptor your body starts to develop
insulin resistance it won't let that
insulin go into the receptor so then
what happens you don't get the signal
back to the pancreas for the pancreas
senses a deficiency and it starts
pumping out more and more insulin to the
point where you're getting five to seven
times more insulin than a normal person
simply because it's not connected over
here so if if I'm ignoring you right now
and I'm not listening to you and I'm not
acknowledging what you're saying
you might start shouting at me because
I'm not receiving that it's the feedback
loop so the point is that if we keep
raising insulin by consuming maybe too
much whey that potentially could
increase your insulin resistance and
create more insulin and more problems so
it's a little complex but I wanted to
cover all the different aspects of what
can increase insulin which thereby can
increase insulin resistance and their
different combinations alright thanks
for watching so if you want more
knowledge on how to create a healthy
body subscribe now and get daily
notifications daily notifications that
sounds weird well I'll just remind you
on a daily basis about that